Um, let's see.
Uh, I mean, okay.
The person who's been holding the longest
now is Jimmy from Philly.
And I know the audience is very mixed about
hearing from him.
But let's just, let's give him a chance and
see what he, what he has to say today.
Yeah.
Yes.
Jimmy.
Yeah.
I'm not claiming Mueller claim
no charges.
What did we, what did they hire this guy for
it?
Yeah.
Punch at the bar.
It's ridiculous.
It's political posts
and you know, think you think that a molar
should've charged Trump.
You're saying?
Um, if there was avenue chats,
well there
they didn't charge him.
It's political.
That's why he punted the mower to keep this
going.
Jenny plead, please don't swear cause we got
to go in and bleep it every single day.
Yeah.
All right.
So do you not believe the evidence that's
in the molar report or did you not look at
it?
There is no evidence.
David, he's allowed to fire.
What's his name?
Uh, he's allowed the fire.
Kone.
Yeah.
If you look at the Mueller report, Mueller
says that actually the firing of Comey met
all three of the requirements to be an obstructive
act as defined by the law.
No, he has the constitutional authority to
fire him or
how do you know more than molar?
Jimmy, are you?
Aren't you a landscaper?
Isn't your expertise in landscaping, not law?
Are you an economist and you go to school
for economy and you're commenting on political
stuff?
Jimmy, the differences, I'm deferring to the
legal experts.
You're saying that the legal experts are wrong?
Yeah, I would say so.
I would say,
Oh, okay, I'm really worried about your drinking
and I would really, I would encourage you,
I don't know if you're going to meetings currently,
but it would really mean a lot to me.
If you started taking this issue seriously
and going to meetings and people write in
and they say, David, I'm in treatment.
Jimmy is in a rough place.
Please encourage him to seek treatment, so
I'm asking you to do that, Jimmy.
Okay.
David, I don't drink as much as you think
I do.
I only think you drink as much as you tell
me.
And it's a lot.
I told you two nights a week.
No you didn't.
I don't know
that that is what I told you.
But listen to this.
I did a little LSD two weeks ago and that
helped me with drinking.
So how old the guy are you, Jimmy?
How old do you think I am?
I was imagining you as 55.
Yeah.
55.
56.
Okay,
well, there you go.
Uh, Jimmy.
All right.
You're worried about you.
I'm worried about you.
I hope that you will get a, you'll, you'll
get the help that you need.
Always.
I'm doing fine, David.
Very good.
All right, Jimmy.
Thank you very much